what did your first few screenplays
teach you about screenwriting that's a
really good question I think some of my
even even like a lot of my early films I
was a huge lover of like horror action
sci-fi action you know I always like
sort of the more supernatural themes or
the more you know the stuff that was
sort of extraordinary because it was I
felt like there were no rules like you
could sort of in terms of story you
could say or do anything you wanted so a
lot of those early scripts were in that
vein it was like you know these huge
epics like I learned very quickly that
when you start out as a writer like
don't write yourself into a situation
where it's something that can't be made
you know I think that's the biggest
thing I learned is uh sometimes you need
to sort of sort of tone it down bring it
back down to the ground a little bit you
know because um we can we can tend to
sort of get really extreme and really
crazy with our ideas and sometimes if
you're just a writer and you don't you
don't do any other part of the process
like you can sort of make things that
are so big and so expensive that you
almost limit your options in terms of
being able to get it made like um you
can you can go to big you know so I
would say that's the thing I learned
early on like um I used to shop a lot of
scripts around and and you know I had
these bluff tea ideas you know and when
it came down to actually making my first
feature I was like okay that's not gonna
happen like weak
now make transformers with no budget so
we got to bring this back down to
reality and so I started to shift my
approach a little bit I started to look
at the things I actually had access to
versus sort of writing about these
things that were just way too big to get
made and so I started looking at my the
resources I had and then let that
influence this story or the the way that
I would write the script for instance if
if I knew somebody with a bar or if I
knew somebody with a garage or whatever
the case is you know I once it came to
actually producing this stuff myself I
started fooling using those resources
and developing stories around those
those things that I knew I could do and
knew I could could could get access to
so that I would set myself up to succeed
you know as far as producing these
projects and I was like I'll I started
out writing these extreme massive
stories and then I was like okay I'm
gonna bring it all the way down to the
ground and then work my way back up to
making bigger and bigger films and
dinner sort of do it that way but yeah
it really came down to like okay let's
let's really get real about what we have
what we don't have what we have access
to what we don't what we can make what
we can't you know and and kind of go
from there you know yes I think that was
the the most important lesson I learned
is to you sort of have the dream and
then you have the reality and you have
to operate based on realistically where
you are what you have and this work your
way up from there
hmm so you saw a movie like tape works
pretty much one location and yeah
absolutely incredible dialogue and the
interaction between the talent but in
terms of maybe some of the technique but
it was your first few screenplays teach
you about that um what was interesting
is because because of my background of
sort of doing it every part of the
process myself I had a slightly
different view of it because when I when
I write I'm already thinking about how
the scene is gonna be done how it's
gonna be shot
what type of shots I'll be using because
I'm also the descent of otago fire so
yeah it definitely I think gave me a
different vantage point of of it because
as I'm writing it I know how it needs to
be shot I know how many shots I'm gonna
need you know I'm already looking at I'm
already sort of breaking it down as I'm
writing it and so I knew like as I'm
writing I know I'm able to do these
things like I know I'm able to produce
these scenes you know what I mean
so I'm able to sort of not limit myself
but I'm able to sort of be be a little
more informed about how I'm writing
these scenes like making sure that I'm
not putting anything on the page that
can't be done you know so yeah I always
said that from that from that standpoint
being the person that is gonna shoot it
who's gonna edit it you know all that
stuff informs the way that I would
approach writing a scene
you